- Yeah, I was a good speller. Yeah.
- Do you want to prove it right now?
- Ohhh, Gosh!
- Okay good because you don't have a choice.
(upbeat music)
- How are you at spelling?
- At spelling?
- (expletive) no!
- I can not believe this is what this is.
- If at any point, I'm here for you,
if you need support...
That's why I'm here.
- It's fifth grade, you should be fine.
- I said I was homeschooled
for God's sake.
- So first word, here we go,
spaghetti.
- I usually call it pasta.
- S-P-A...
- G...
- There's a secret H in there somewhere.
- I don't know how to spell spaghetti!
- E-T-I?
- T-T-I, spaghetti.
- That is correct.
- Oh, yes!
- Correct.
(groans)
- That is correct, good job!
- That is not correct.
- I know.
- When have I ever had to spell spaghetti?
- Humiliated.
(both laugh)
Give it to me!
- No. No.
- Kids stay in school.
Don't become actors.
- Next word is diarrhea.
- Ah, (expletive)!
Uh, uh, literally. Um...
- You went right to it, you now this one.
- These are all like hidden H words.
D-I-A...
- I hate this game.
R-R-E-A-H?
- I'm going to tell her
she's right no matter what.
- I'm missing an R.
- Yeah, just throw it in there somewhere.
- Die-uh-rhea
- D-I-O-R-R-H-E-A?
- So sorry, that is terrible diarrhea.
- R-H-E-A?
- Correct! Wow!
- You know your diarrhea.
- I know my diarrhea.
- Last one might be the hardest,
mediterranean.
- Can we call a friend? (laughs)
- M-E-D-I-T-T...
- A-R...
- R-
- Oh!
- How's that?
- [Interviewer] Smiley face.
- Smiley face ending.
- That was very wrong.
(all sing) ♫ All that we
could do with this emotion ♫
- M-E-D-I-T-E-R-R-E-A-N-E-A-N?
- Correct!
Correct! (celebrates)
You're the first person
to spell mediterranean.
- That is bad.
- Well you know if I get any word wrong...
I don't mind getting diarrhea wrong
because maybe it's just
not an issue I have.
Sooo...
- The only one I do know how to spell.
Do with that information what you will.